or at the Miami Book Fair International
for the 2006 Book Fair and Charles
Shields is with us inside the book TV
bus he has a new book called Mockingbird
a portrait of Harper Lee how do you
explain to your readers the importance
of Harper Lee in the culture of American
history we just have to look at the
facts thirty million copies of the book
were sold have been sold since its
publication in 1960 it's read in two
thirds of American public high schools
that continues to sell hundreds of
thousands of copies a year and in
surveys of American readers when they're
asked to rank the top five most
influential books in their lives the
Kill a Mockingbird is always on that
list in fact the only book that ranks
higher consistently is the Bible so and
why do you think that happened I mean
have you ever have there's been a lot
written about why it's so influential
have you taken a different take on that
or well I think that it takes people
back to a time when there's a strong
sense of community and adults cared
about children and you knew your
neighbors and when people start to read
To Kill a Mockingbird they're in a small
town and they want to stay so yes
there's big themes of justice and
tolerance and things like that but I
think it's because they can they can put
their their feet down on that dusty
Street in Alabama in the 1930s and
they're there so she has a wonderful way
of taking readers into the lives of
those characters because she was there
she was they waited she brought she grew
up in Monroeville Alabama during the
1930s and she is Scout to a tee
that's Harper Lee and instantly her
first name is Nell which is her
grandmother's name Ellen spelled
backwards and her father was an attorney
AC Lee he's the model for Atticus Finch
her mother was Frances Cunningham Finch
her name was changed to Lee obviously
when she married and Nick her next door
neighbor was Truman Capote
who was the model for dill so she had a
very rich fun of personalities to draw
and the book is highly autobiographical
where did the now turn into Harper
please daddy well she she dropped no
because she disliked it when people
pronounced her name Nelly and she tried
out Harper Lee a couple of times in the
student newspaper at the University of
Alabama and I guess she liked the kind
of gender neutral effect and she didn't
put Nell on the cover to kill a
mockingbird where did she go to college
she went to the University of Alabama at
the end of World War two although she
did spend a year at Huntington which is
what at that time was an all-girls
Methodist school in Montgomery but she
transferred after her freshman year she
intended to graduate from law school at
the University of Alabama but as she
said to friends later she just loved it
she did not like law and that was a
great disappointment to her father
because of her older elder sister Alice
who's still alive incidentally is 96
years old and practicing law three days
a week in Monroeville her eldest sister
Alice had entered the law firm and her
father held hopes held out hopes that
Alice and Nell would one day be in the
firm with him and he used to tell a
little joke around town that someday he
may have to change the name of the law
firm to lien Daughters attorneys but
then Nell announced that she didn't want
to go on so when she left the University
of Alabama she left without a degree and
did what did she like though did she
write she license she left Alabama and
she went to New York City I suspect it
was at the urging of Truman Truman had
had a big hit in 1948 with other voices
other rooms and I can just hear him
saying listen if you if you really want
to be a writer you've got to come to the
literary capital of the world which is
New York so she went to New York but she
did not make the kind of splash that she
expected by any means
she lived in a Coldwater flat in the
German neighborhood where Lou Gehrig
grew up as a matter of fact and she
worked as an airline reservation ax
stand for about seven or eight years she
wrote during the night and on weekends
and published nothing so nothing not a
magazine article nothing not a thing
effects when she brought the manuscript
to her future editor Tejo ha fat
Lippincott she had never been published
and Howe Hoff was surprised
that you hadn't at least put her toe
into the water and that this was her
first effort what she hoped would be a
full-fledged novel was this because of
her of her big so I Shire or was it
because she just wasn't that good um I
think a combination of both
although when she was little she was
very forceful and she was known as a
court of a playground bully actually
when she grew older she was withdrawn
not to the point of being antisocial
exactly but just kind of like you say
shy and she had doubts about whether she
could write fiction and in fact those
doubts almost discouraged her when she
brought the manuscript to Lippincott and
she sat down with her future editor and
was told by Tejo HOF um you know what
you've written our a series of anecdotes
and sketches there it's not really a
novel it doesn't have that arc of
development it's individual tales from a
small town and if Mel Harper Lee had
been less determined at that point she
might have said you know what I've been
working on this for seven or eight years
now this isn't a novel or at least close
to a novel but instead to her credit she
worked another two and a half years
writing and rewriting to the point as a
matter of fact where one night she was
working on the book and in out of total
despair she picked up the entire
manuscript walked over to a window in
her apartment opened it and through what
would become one of the best-selling
novels of the 20th century out in the
alley and closed the window was this
before or after she went to do some
research for Truman Capote this is
before the time when she did research
for Truman Capote was an in-between time
for her it was when To Kill a
Mockingbird was in galleys and was about
to be proof read and she was waiting for
those galleys picture of her garden city
can Garden City Kansas right so she was
she was waiting for her first novel ever
to come out she was very excited Truman
said we'd like to go on this jaunt with
me it should be exciting and it was
exciting more than they could ever have
imagined and incidentally Harper Lee
never anticipated that the Kill
Mockingbird would be
kind of hit that it was her editor told
her Nellie you're a first-time novelist
nobody knows your name
if you sell 2500 copies you should be
proud because that's the way these
careers go you start off small and you
build up so of course when it became a
New York Times bestseller and a major
motion picture and she won the Pulitzer
Prize she was stunned absolutely stunned
and what did she do then
well she granted interviews up until
about 1965 pretty steadily and she
talked about her second book I worded
movie come in and all of that which
which movie now oh the movie came in
yeah the movie uh tequila Mockingbird
with Gregory Peck came out in was made
during 62 and also I think came out that
year as well and she was very happy with
it incidentally although she didn't
write the script horton Foote did she
was pleased with the movie so it was a
meteoric rise and she was set to create
her second novel but it never
materialized and in fact when a BBC
reporter stopped by Monroeville in the
early 1970s to do a little piece on
Harper Lee where is she he asked her
sister Alice what did happen in the
second book your sister said she was
working on and Alice said a burglar
broke in and stole it which to me sounds
like the dog ate my homework when
tequila Mockingbird was released can you
explain what the what the reaction of
the American readership was was it
immediate was it later it was immediate
it was a sensation the book sold almost
a half a million copies by the end of
1960 by the year of its publication it
came out July 1960 she was squarely on
the map as a literary phenomenon and she
was up against some tough competition
that year there was a I think there was
rabbit run by John Updike and the the
pinnacle of American literature was you
know taking place at that time the
American literature was really a
worldwide in terms of its influence and
so to enter that kind of league of
writers so quickly was was just
unimaginable for her where is she today
well she spends a few months of the year
in New York
and she spends most of the time they'll
Monroeville Alabama living in the same
house of her sister Alice
neither of the ladies have married and
if you go to Dave's Dave catfish cabin
on Saturday you'll see them they're
having of the child's portion of hush
puppies and catfish and their hearing
aids go wee and they argue about whose
noise whose is doing it and they are
just two elderly ladies in a small
southern town and what kind of access
did you have to her for this book well I
have to say that she did not want me to
do the book and she even contacted
people that she thought I would
eventually get to some of whom I did go
to and asked them not to speak to me why
nelle Harper Lee likes to be in control
she is the kind of person you have to
seek permission from and that's all well
I did initially I said I sent her a
letter and I tried to curry favor with
her and I asked for her cooperation and
I heard nothing back however her sister
Alice did write back to me occasionally
answering some very specific questions
that I asked but she has always been the
buffer between her younger sister in the
outside world
Nelly and her family was always regarded
as countable a bohemian and a rebel and
Alice the eldest sister a lawyer has
handed her handles her finances and her
legal arrangements for all of Nels
career I was interested in reading where
how you found some of the people that
you decided to interview you interviewed
600 people approximately now right and I
need to I need to put this little
codicil to that which is that some of
the people I contact many of course
don't have a vivid historical
imagination and when you say did you
know nelle Harper Lee they say oh sure
she's great that's what cool can you
tell me about her oh she's a lot of fun
you'd love her that doesn't do me any
good so there were a lot of you know
interviews on that level but there are
also some very very vivid ones too and
and the way that I found people was I
went to classmates.com and I found
people she'd gone to school with and I
went to the University of Alabama
directory and found her sorority sisters
and I just looked high and low
for everybody who might have sat next to
her in algebra class or or you know live
next to extort or in New York I even
went to phone books from 1950s is so
without modern technology this would
have been a really difficult research
project it would have yes yes it would
because she left no traces of you as a
writer this is your first book no
actually I wrote a book for young people
for a long time I wrote young adult
biographies and histories from about
1997 until 2004 or 2003 are they still
in print oh yeah who did you write about
well I wrote about Amy Tan the
chinese-american author and I wrote
about Mahatma Gandhi I wrote two history
books like the plague and Fire of London
you see I taught high school for a long
time and so when I decided to write full
time I went for the audience that I knew
best which was young people and I wrote
books that I thought that they could use
for their reports or to give them
specific information for example if
you're going to do a report on the
Battle of the Bulge you don't want a big
thick book you know by William Shire on
the rise of the Third Reich
you want just a well-written interesting
book that's vivid about the Battle of
the Bulge and that's what I wrote about
I decided to take this on really to
answer a mystery which is how could so
little be known about one of the most
popular officers of authors of the 20th
century if when you were teaching high
school did you teach human bird I talked
to kill a mockingbird and the kids
always wanted to know more about the
author because I would I would get them
into the landscape of the book I would
orient them to where we were going to be
I would even get out of map and say okay
we're going to be in this part of the
south and let's review what the
Depression was all about that sort of
thing and then once I got into the
spirit of that they would start to say
things like well is it a man or a woman
is she Scout is she live or dead and
when you look into an encyclopedia
there's so little about the woman just
to give you an example of how there's
such a paucity of information
encyclopedias will say for example that
she graduated from the University of
Alabama which she didn't some will say
she went to Oxford University for a year
she only went to summer school
exchange program a student some will say
she went on a Fulbright she didn't but
all of them will agree that she's a
direct descendant of robert e lee which
she is not so that gives you an idea
about the amount of misinformation about
this woman who's alive and and and well
and has a lot of friends what's been the
reaction of folks to this biography well
it's been a popular book audiences at
bookstores are very curious about her
and about the movie any other people who
knew knew or know her commanded lee sin
would work
yes I had a sorority sister come up to
me so every sister of hers come up to me
and introduce herself and a couple of
distant relatives from that part of the
country they were very gracious I didn't
get the sense that they were at all you
know bothered by the book I have had a
few people come up to me say well how
would you like a biography written about
you and my answer is I wanted to capture
the memories of some of these people
before they passed away because Nell
tends to be friends with rather ordinary
people playing people you know walk of
life people and if I don't capture them
now what will happen in the course of my
research six my correspondence passed
away really valuable people I was
talking to who are in their 80s and just
just died of natural causes and how they
knew her when she was growing up is gone
so I'm proud to have gotten started on
this because if I had waited who knows
what would have been available the
picture we showed earlier was from 2005
how old is she today um let's see she's
in her early 80s she's 81 I believe this
is the book it's called Mockingbird a
portrait of Harper Lee the author is
Charles Shield thanks for